let's start with the highest
philosophical question
do you think human beings are
fundamentally good or
are all of us capable of both good and
evil
and it's the environment that molds how
we uh the trajectory that we take
through life
how do we define evil evil seems to be a
situational eye of the beholder kind of
question
so if we define evil maybe i can get a
better idea of
and and that could be a whole show
couldn't defining evil but
but when we say evil what do we mean
that's a slippery one but i think
there's some way in which your existence
your presence in the world leads to
pain and suffering and destruction for
many others
in the rest of the world so you you
steal the resources
and you use them to create more
suffering than there was before
in the world so i suppose it's somehow
deeply connected to
this other slippery word which is
suffering
as you create suffering in the world you
bring suffering to the world
but here's the problem i think with it
because i i fully see where you're going
with that
and i i understand it the problem is is
the question
of the reason for inflicting suffering
so sometimes one might inflict suffering
upon
one group of individuals in order to
maximize
a lack of suffering with another group
of individuals or one
who might not be considered evil at all
might make the rational
seemingly rational choice of inflicting
pain and suffering on a smaller group of
people
in order to maximize the opposite of
that for a larger group of people
yeah that's one of the dark things about
i've spoken and read the work of stephen
codkin i'm not sure if you're familiar
with the historian
and he's basically a stalin uh joseph
stalin scholar
and one of the things i realized i'm not
sure where to put hitler
but with stalin it really seems
that he was sane
and he thought he was doing good for the
world he i
i really believe from everything i've
read about stalin
that he believed that communism
is good for the world and if you have to
kill a few people along the way if it's
like you said the small groups if you
have to
sort of remove the people that stand in
the way of this utopian system
of communism then that's actually good
for the world and it didn't seem
to me that he could even consider the
possibility that he was evil
he really thought he was doing good for
the world and that stuck with me because
he's one of the most
is to our definition of evil he seems to
have brought more evil onto this world
than almost any human in history
and i don't know what to do with that
well i'm fascinated with the concept so
fascinated by it that the very first
hardcore history show we ever did which
was a full 15 or 16 minutes
um was called alexander versus hitler
and the entire question about it was
the motivations right so if you go to a
court of law because you killed somebody
one of the things they're going to
consider is why did you kill them
right and if you killed somebody for
example in self-defense
you're going to be treated differently
than if you malicious kill kill somebody
maliciously to take their wallet right
and in the show we we wondered because
you know i don't really make uh
pronouncements but we wondered about uh
if you believe
hitler's writings for example mineconf
uh which you know is written by a guy
who's a political figure who wants to
get
so i mean it's about as as believable as
any other political tract would be
but in his mind the things that he said
that he had to do
were designed to for the betterment of
the german people right
whereas alexander the great once again
this is somebody from more than 2000
years ago so
with lots of propaganda in the
intervening years but one of the
the views of alexander the great is that
the reason he did what he did was
to for lack of a better word write his
name in a more permanent graffiti on the
pages of history right in other words to
glorify himself
and if that's the case does that make
alexander a worse person than hitler
because
hitler thought he was doing good whereas
alexander if you believe the
interpretation was simply trying to
exalt alexander
so the the motivations of the people
doing these things it seems to me
matter i don't think you can just sit
there and go the only thing that matters
is the end result because that might
have been an
unintentional byproduct uh in which case
that person had you been able to show
them the future
might have changed what they were doing
so were they evil or misguided or wrong
or made the wrong you know so and i hate
to do that because there's certain
people like hitler that i don't feel
deserve the benefit of the doubt
at the same time if you're fascinated by
the concept of evil
and you delve into it deeply enough
you're going to want to understand
why these evil people did what they did
and sometimes
it can confuse the hell out of you you
know who wants to sit there and try to
see things from hitler's point of view
to get a better understanding and sort
of commiserate with
so um but i'm fa obviously first history
show i'm fascinated with the concept
so do you think it's possible if we put
ourselves in the mindset of some of the
people that have
led created so much suffering in the
world
that all of them had their motivations
were
had good intentions underlying them no
i don't i mean simply because there's so
many i mean the law of averages would
would suggest that that's not true i
guess it as pure evil
possible meaning you uh again
it's slippery but you the suffering
is the goal suffering intentional
suffering yeah
yes i think that and i think that
there's historical figures that that
that one could point
and but that gets to the deeper question
of are these people saying
uh do they have something wrong with
them are they twisted from something in
their youth
um you know i mean
these are the kinds of things where
where you start to delve into the
psychological makeup of these people
in other words is anybody born evil and
i actually believe that some people are
i think the dna can get scrambled up in
ways i think the question of evil is
important too because i think it's an
eye of the beholder thing i mean if
hitler for example had been successful
and we were today on the sixth or
seventh leader of the third reich since
i think his entire history would be
viewed through a different lens because
that's the way we do things right um
genghis khan looks different to the
mongolians than he does to the residents
of baghdad right um
and i think so so an eye of the beholder
question i think comes into all these
sorts of things
as you said it's a very slippery
question
you